américains et talibans se sont donc
posées autour d'une même table ce
week-end au qatar une première rencontre
en face à face depuis que les
fondamentalistes ont repris le pouvoir
en afghanistan il ya deux mois on en
parle tout de suite avec un autre
correspondant thomas bonnin washington
bonsoir thomas alors des discussions
plutôt franche et professionnel selon
les mots du département d'état américain
oui c'est en effet ce qu'affirme le
communiqué publié ce week-end par le
département d'état américain à l'issue
de ces deux jours d'échangés entre
représentants américains et
représentants des talibans des échanges
qui se sont déroulés à doha au qatar le
communiqué indique que les états unis
ont mis l'accent sur la sécurité et le
terrorisme avec l'objectif de permettre
le rapatriement des ressortissants
américains toujours en afghanistan
accent qui a aussi été mis sur la
fameuse inclusivité réclamé par
washington depuis le début à l'égard des
talibans c'est aussi ce qu'a mis en
lumière ce lundi le chef de l'onu
antonio guterres est ce qui a fait part
de ses inquiétudes écouter mais
je suis particulièrement alarmés de voir
les promesses faites aux femmes et aux
filles afghanes par les talibans ne pas
être respecté les promesses non tenues
conduisent à des rêves brisés pour les
femmes qui les fuit d'afghanistan
alors lors des échanges qui ont eu lieu
ce week-end au qatar entre les
représentants américains et les
représentants des talibans il ya
vraisemblablement eu au moins un point
d'accord le fait que les etats-unis
puissent à moyen terme à savoir dans les
prochaines semaines acheminer de l'aide
humanitaire à destination de la
population afghane aide humanitaire qui
pourrait également contenir des doses de
vaccin contre le coronavirus on en
revanche aucune autre information sur de
quelconques accord qui aurait pu être
trouvé entre les deux parties on sait en
revanche qu'il ya eu au moins un point
de désaccord puisque les représentants
des talibans ont affirmé qu'ils avaient
refusé de travailler avec les états unis
sur la lutte contre l'état islamique
estimant qu'il pouvait faire ce travail
de manière totalement indépendante alors
on rappelle qu'il s'agissait des
premiers échanges formels officielle
entre les deux parties depuis le retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan à
la fin du mois d'août côté taliban on
estime que d'autres réunions pourrez
suivre ces premiers échanges d'ailleurs
vous la vie dit il y aura demain une
autre réunion entre les représentants
des talibans et des représentants de
l'union européenne et puis côté
américain on rappelle que ces échanges
ne constituent en aucun cas une
reconnaissance officielle du
gouvernement formé par les talibans
c'est un dossier très compliqué pour
washington qui marche sur des oeufs
parce que d'un côté évidemment
washington veut garder une prise sur les
enjeux de la région montrait aussi
qu'elle n'abandonne pas les
ressortissants américains est également
les afghans qui ont travaillé avec les
américains pendant toutes ces années
qu'a duré la guerre en afghanistan et
puis de l'autre washington ne veut pas
non plus donner une trop forte
légitimité au gouvernement formé par les
talibans merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington